تتحرك الحكومة الروسية
بسرعة كبيرة للتصالح مع الوضع الجديد
على الأرض في
أفغانستان وبالطبع في كابول بالتحديد في
الواقع لقد جاء السفير الروسي في كابول
وأكد يوم الثلاثاء
أنه عقد اجتماعات مع كبار المسؤولين.
قال مسؤولون من طالبان الآن
إن طالبان قد ضمنت
أمن وسلامة السفارة الروسية
وموظفيها وأيضاً أن
طالبان لديها على ما يبدو ما أسماه
موقفاً إيجابياً تجاه روسيا الآن ،
وهذا يختلف كثيراً عن الحديث
الذي نحن فيه.  لقد سمعنا من الروس
في اليومين الماضيين عن حكومة أشرف
غني التي
دعمتها بالطبع الولايات المتحدة ،
ووصف الروس تلك الحكومة بأنها
حكومة دمية ويقولون إنهم
يعتقدون الآن أن طالبان في
الأساس في السلطة في كابول وأن الوضع
هناك  يستقر بشكل عام
لكن الروس يقولون إن هذا
لا يغير بالضرورة
موقفهم من طالبان في  حقيقة أن
سيرجي لافروف خرج لأول
مرة يوم الثلاثاء وقال إن
الروس قد رأوا بعض الإشارات الإيجابية
ولكن من ناحية أخرى بالطبع
لا تزال طالبان منظمة
محظورة في روسيا وتعتبر
منظمة إرهابية هنا أيضًا
في  كلها لكن الروس
يقولون
إنهم يعتقدون أنهم في وضع مريح إلى حد ما
في كابول وفي
أفغانستان لأنهم لفترة طويلة جدًا
كانوا يطورون العلاقات مع جميع
الأطراف في أفغانستان على وجه التحديد أيضًا
مع طالبان ، فإن الروس لديهم
مصالح كبيرة في  بالطبع في أفغانستان حيث أن
العديد من الدول الحليفة مثل
طاجيكستان وأوزبكستان
تشترك في حدود طويلة مع
أفغانستان والروس بالتأكيد لا يريدون أن
يروا زعزعة الاستقرار في هذا الجزء من
العالم فريد بلاكين CNN موسكو